[музика]
знайшли на вашого діагностичні тести
давайте розбиратись як із ними працювати
діагностичні тести створення щоб
допомогти вчителям виявити чи учні мають
прогавини та у які конкретна темі а
учням перевірити власні знання та вміння
на платформі всеукраїнська школа онлайн
доступні тести з математики та
української мови для 5-7 і 9 класів
тести охоплюють основні теми за
попередні два роки навчання тож
застосувати тестування можна і на
початку 5 класу і в кінці четвертого щоб
перевірити як учні засвоїли вивчене щоб
пройти тест учнів та ученицям потрібно
бути користувачами платформи вшо знайти
тест у розділі курси та зареєструватись
для його складання під час проходження
тесту Важливо уважно слідкувати за
інструкціями та підказками платформи
обираючи правильну відповідь натискати
кнопку надіслати після кожного завдання
слідкувати за часом та бути уважним щоб
не пропустити якогось питання тести
розроблені таким чином що їх можуть
проходити учні і вдома і на уроці звіт
про свою успіхи учень чи учениця може
переглянути зазирнувши у розділ прогрес
звіт для учнівства на оцінка це детальна
аналітика успіхів у засвоєнні тем там
дитина знайде інформацію про те Скільки
завдань вдалось виконати Правильно а в
яких були допущені помилки щоб
надолужити прогалини з конкретної теми у
звіті учень чи учениця знайдуть
посилання на навчальні матеріали
підібрані авторами тесту Вчителі ж
можуть отримати звіт про успіхи у тесті
для всього класу для цього вчителя або
вчительці потрібно бути користувачами
платформи вшо скопіювати відповідний
курс з діагностичними тестами та за
допомогою інструментів у кабінеті
вчителя запросити учнів наприклад 5-б
класу до проходження тесту для цього
Учні повинні мати власну електронну
пошту та бути заре на платформі вшо зі
статусом учень чи учениця отримавши на
електронну скриньку запрошення пройти
тест учням слід Перейти за посиланням
листів щоб вчитель зміг отримати звіт
про їхні результати доступність тестів
онлайн дозволяє вчити нові провести
діагностування окремих учнів чи класу як
на уроці так і віддалено давши тест як
домашні завдання
термін проходження тесту вчитель може
визначити самостійно коли ж учні
виконають завдання тесту вчитель може
згенерувати та завантажити звіт у якому
знайде узагальнені дані про успішність
класу та теми над якими треба додатково
попрацювати щоб надолужити прогалине в
учнів учитель має змогу переглянути
також індивідуальний звіт кожного учня
чи учениці ввівши у розділ оцінювання
електронну адресу за якою дитина
зареєстрована досягнення у вивченні тем
можна перевірити двічі
спершу за допомогою первинного
тестування а після додаткового
опрацювання тем виконати тест для
вторинної діагностики Таким чином
вчитель та учні зможуть перевірити чи
вдалось надолужити прогалини
діагностичні тести доступні для усіх
бажаючих на платформі всеукраїнської
школи онлайн у розділі курси